and so now we're going to use that
property where it's sort of a going
universe to prove this what are we
saying about these two tangents
what are we suggesting about them that
they are equal okay so I'm going to
suggest a construction will be really
useful to prove that that is the case
that these two tangents are perp and
sorry not perpendicular are equal what's
the stock standard construction that you
always put on a circle when you don't
know what else to do the radius from the
center right now in this case I've got
two points on the circumference so
therefore I'm going to draw both of the
radii okay now I'm going to start to
piece together the proof to give you PA
and PB I'm going to give you one clue
before I let you have a go on your own I
suggested that we would have to use this
property that the tangent is
perpendicular to the radius where where
can I put in these right angles where do
they belong if the center is o which are
their right angles a which there are
there are two right angles of this
diagram where are they they've got names
what would you call them P PB o because
PB is a tangent and OB is the radius at
the point of contact you agree so that
their property got where's the other one
PA okay by the way quick note think back
to last week when we talked about cyclic
quadrilateral z' see how this is 90 and
this is 90 so what can you tell me about
Oh a P and B what can you tell me about
those points if the opposite angles are
both 90 the opposite angles are
supplementary what kinds of
quadrilaterals have opposite angles that
are supplementary
do you remember cyclic contouring
circles right cyclic quadrilateral have
opposite angles in the supplementary so
if you wanted to you have this shape now
you could find the center of this and
you can draw a circle that went through
all of those four points okay I'm going
to pause for a minute I've given you
some clues give you quite a few
actually how can you use this
information to show that these two
lengths are a P what we've required to
prove is that ap is equal to BP have a
shot if you've got something call me
ever
okay proved inverted commas alright what
I'm going to do is I'm going to show you
the proof that I originally intended and
then I'm very interested but just an
orogeny both proved a different way the
same different way you've proved it the
same way but it's not the way that I
prove it which is cool so let me show
you how I would do it like this okay
when I made this construction o P I
divided our quadrilateral up there into
two triangles and then not just any two
triangles these two triangles you can
clearly see look congruent don't they so
can I prove that that is the case it's
not that hard okay have a look you know
how we constructed these radii right so
the radii are clearly going to be equal
right in addition to having equal radio
you also have these equal angles but
they're not just equal angles they are
right angled right they're right angled
and then lastly the side I constructed
in the middle o pé is shared in common
by both triangles right so in fact this
is an RHS proof do you see that it's an
RHS proof right angle I've got the
hypotenuse if it's opposite the right
angle and then I've got a shorter side
so if they are congruent then what yeah
then corresponding sides of congruent
triangles are equal so you done okay but
you didn't have to prove it that way
let's do it this way though I will say
it takes a bit of a tiny bit of
finagling around but it works it's fine
so if you construct a B instead okay
correct me if I'm wrong as I go through
this and just do it from your memory
okay if you construct a B then just like
over here you've created not congruent
triangles but ice and ice or something's
trying to at least over here right which
means if I call this guy say theta and
this theta because they're equal right I
can now say on the other side in this
other triangle because I know I've
proven earlier those are 90 degrees
what's this angle
equal to its the compliment yeah 90
minus theta and by the same logic this
is also the compliment of theta well if
you've got two angles and they're both
going to be the same you've created a
second isosceles triangle up here equal
sides are opposite equal angles that's
nice isn't it maybe I like that better
actually because you don't have to
appeal to triangle conference okay so
does that make sense
java never rehearse that last bit yeah
you can't say base angles with an
isosceles triangle are equal but then to
to state that you have to proceed that
by proving that it's isosceles which you
don't need to do you can just have them
being equal angles that's enough okay